all right welcome back everyone
all right so for the you know last talk
of the morning you know we're super
excited to have our own uh amy greenwald
here to tell us about her work on you
know learning and regret minimization
and extensive for games so i'll let you
take it away excellent thank you very
much
thanks so much for inviting me thanks
for the all of the workshops i've been
here six weeks it's been delightful
so thank you again
i'd also like to thank my collaborators
there's quite a few
a bunch of them names you'll recognize
like mark was here yesterday uh people
at alberta at deepmind rico is a student
of mine at brown now at mit and the work
that i'm presenting today is primarily
from the thesis of dustin morill who is
a student at alberta
all right
so i think we've seen this slide or
something like it a few times by now but
i think we'll all admit that there has
been tremendous success
in recent years
with ai learning to play games very well
uh i guess not just in recent years but
for decades now
all of these games that i'm showing you
here on this slide are games of complete
information
but we've also seen recent success in
poker a game of incomplete information
or imperfect information so
most of the success
a good part of poker success
is
kind of
due to this
very influential algorithm called
counterfactual regret minimization which
minimizes regret in extensive form games
these are all extensive form games where
you know one player takes a turn like
chess like you have the whole game tree
one player takes a turn another player
takes a turn and so on but we have a
whole game tree that we're reasoning
about so counterfactual regret
minimization the key to poker successes
they're an extensive form game where
there is some hidden information right
so think about poker you have your cards
and your opponent doesn't necessarily
see your cards so you're playing a game
where part of the state is is not
revealed
this is quite a
monumental important result
for extensive form games and this talk
will be about generalizing this
algorithm uh beyond games like poker
which are zero sum games to non-zero sum
games
so just to remind everybody here knows
uh i think but just to remind you all we
have normal form games which look like
this i think mark showed the exact same
game yesterday and you know it came from
wikipedia so if you're not familiar with
it you can go read about it
here is a picture of an extensive form
game also from wikipedia
kind of blurry screenshot
the important thing to notice here is
that
an exten and gabriele talked about this
yesterday
talking about the relationship between
extensive and normal form games when we
reason about extensive form games we
could if we wanted to kind of look at
them in their normal form representation
with which they do have but the problem
is the normal form representation leads
to a blow up and in general an
exponential blow up and you can kind of
see that in this picture because the
normal form representation is showing
you just to explain this picture we have
two players player one and player two
and player one is moving up here at the
top node they can go left or right and
then player two will move at either of
these two nodes and they have two
choices k and u so the strategies are
functions you can think of them as
functions from these decision points to
the possible actions
so what we're looking at here in this
representation is you know kk here means
for player two when they're at their
decision point one they could play k and
when they're at their decision point two
they could play k
right so we're listing kind of the whole
function the whole strategy here versus
all of the you know the other players
all of their strategies they have only l
and r here and and putting in these
payouts but you'll notice repeat numbers
right you have repeat numbers you have
kind of too much information there so
what we want is we want to be able to
reason about extensive form games but in
the compactor in a compact
representation not in a normal form
representation which would lead to this
kind of blow up so that's our goal we're
concerned about the representation
complexity
all right so here is sort of a usual
picture a lot of people have talked
about next slide is going to tell you
what regret minimization is i'm sure
everybody knows but here's my model
so
we have a learner
the learner is playing some policy
indicated here i is
us the learner and uh t is the current
policy at time t so that policy along
with the opponent's policies gets fed
into a game
and out pops a utility which the learner
can now learn from and likewise the
other players will see their utilities
and they can learn from them as well
okay so one important point is that from
the point of view of the learner you
know whatever the other players are
doing and whatever's in the game
environment all of this
part of the game all this is just uh
we're just considering all of that to be
the environment i think we've seen that
perspective many times this week
all right and so what does it mean to
minimize regret we've also heard the
language of being rational in hindsight
used this week and so what does that
mean well it means if the learner is
playing this sequence of strategies or
policies pi for policy i guess but okay
so
uh what the learner can consider are
deviations from
their policies so a deviation here is a
function applied to the policy and
saying hey let's do some other function
of our policy instead of our policy
so you can calculate the total utility
that's obtained from a policy as
compared to the total utility you would
obtain from deviating so by applying a
deviation function to the policy at each
time
so that gives you your total utility of
the deviation and what it means to
minimize regret is to say well for some
class of possible deviations
for all of them i could consider what
was my utility when i used the deviation
versus what was my utility of my own
policy
and if the utility i'm getting from
using my own policy is
high enough there's a little bit of
leeway here but if it's high enough i'm
happy and i don't have regret
specifically i don't have regret with
respect to this class of deviations
okay
make sense
and as we heard from
many people we
know how to achieve this we've known how
to achieve this notion of regret for
you know 50 plus years
okay great
all right so what i want to talk about
is the relationship between this kind of
regret
and equilibria in games
and again this is you know a bit of
history this is stuff that has been
known for
uh for the normal swarm case in
particular for a large number of years
so here's what we know here's kind of a
summary of the normal form story
so
there are two kinds of regret that are
important in normal form games they're
called external and internal regret we
heard about them yesterday and and many
other times and i think by now everyone
in this audience
would have heard if they don't know the
proof at least at least they've heard
the fact that if you minimize external
regret you will end up converging to
coarse correlated equilibrium while if
you minimize internal regret you can
converge to correlated equilibrium if
you don't know what those terms mean i
am going to tell you what those terms
mean in a few slides but for now that's
just a fact that you have anyway heard
several times this week
all right and there are some qualifiers
on the notion of convergence so it's
important to realize that this
convergence is kind of in average
iterates or the empirical distribution
is what's converging and actually it's
not exactly converging it's converging
to a set which means it's always kind of
at least arbitrarily close to that set
but maybe not reaching any particular
point
okay so one paper that i worked on
now 20 years ago
was asking the question
what if we try to consider other kinds
of deviations besides just internal and
external regret deviations
so what if we kind of threw into the mix
stronger or alternative or more
deviations could we then converge to a
stronger notion of equilibrium
so we studied this question
and what we found was first of all that
it was quite easy to consider internal
and external regret kind of along the
lines of a single continuum again i'm
going to show you these definitions in a
bit
um
and moreover that we could then and we
call this continuum fee regret so that's
where the letter phi of the set of
deviations comes from
and moreover that we could come up with
an algorithm that was efficient and
could minimize fee regret for
any set of deviations v
and then we have the natural
generalization that you end up at a no
if you have no fee regret learning that
you end up at a fee equilibrium okay so
what the point here is that the set of
deviations
is defining the set of equilibrium so
here i'm using phi as my set of
deviations and phi as my notion of
equilibrium what we saw in the past was
external deviations lead to
course-correlated equilibrium and
internal lead to correlated equilibrium
but we have sort of a whole continuum
potential here yes
yeah so we're going to come to more
details about that and that's really
going to be the focus so maybe we can
hold that and and and come back to that
but yeah but we can do uh efficient
no fear it's important that we can do
efficient learning um in normal form
games
so we were kind of wondering you know
let's throw more fee more deviations
into our bag of deviations and can we
get more strategic power
what we found was that the answer was no
that in fact
the internal regret deviations were
getting us all the power that we could
possibly get no matter what we threw
into that bag
so that was the strongest form of no few
regret learning and there kind of wasn't
uh much reason to think about other
kinds of deviations let me just
have add one caveat here which is that
some people say that swap regret
is what leads to correlated equilibrium
so swap regret is a little bit different
than internal and i'm also going to talk
about that but we can be thinking about
you know no internal or no swap as the
um as the strongest form here
all right so that's the story from
normal from games and that's
2003. now we move to 2007 and we have
kind of a breakthrough in the extensive
form game world
where
we get an external regret minimizing
algorithm
for
um for extensive form games all right so
let me just give a brief idea what
external and internal are
so external is the usual kind that
dating back to foreign and and and what
most of us here when we say that we have
a regret minimizing algorithm what we
mean we're just looking at the best
fixed action in hindsight
so looking at the best fixed action in
hindsight in an extensive form game
means looking at the best strategy the
best path through the whole tree
right
so that's what it means to have no
external regret in an extensive form
game
but the problem is that there are a lot
of these paths
there are too many of these paths if you
think about it there are exponentially
many paths that you have to compare to
and so the the brilliance of the
counterfactual regret minimization
algorithm was that we were going to
compare to all of the strategies in the
extern in the extensor form game but we
were going to do that efficiently so
without having to enumerate all of these
exponentially many strategies
okay so that was sort of the cleverness
there and maybe the reason the result
was surprising and you know we could now
solve poker or come close to because we
had this way of efficiently doing as
well as the best fixed strategy in
hindsight being all the possible
strategies through the tree
all right
okay so what so that's 2007 and what
about now that that that was a beautiful
result by the way again for zero sum
games i might have forgotten to say that
just
but what about non-zero sun games so von
stengel and forge thinking about
extensive form non-zero-sum games
and
what we would maybe like or to think
about is to think about uh generalizing
the internal case right so
the when we minimized internal regret in
normal form games we found correlated
equilibria and so maybe we can somehow
minimize internal regret in extensive
form games and we would find correlated
equilibria here in extensive form games
as well i mean actually we would do that
if we could do that so the problem and
now let me tell you what internal is and
maybe also swap so what internal regret
means is that when i'm given a
recommended action i'm given i'm i'm
thinking or what i'm playing when i'm
playing one action at all the times that
i was playing this one action i don't
wish that i were playing another action
so instead of just switching um just
having switching to all of your fixed
actions you kind of condition on what
you were doing
and so at the time that you were doing
the one thing you don't wish that you
were doing something else
so
um
if we think about kind of how many of
these deviations we have
one way to think about it is just if n
is your number of actions that you have
n squared of those
right that you can just kind of go from
everything you were doing to everything
else you might doing for be doing for
fixed actions but actually when we look
at this in the external world sorry i
keep getting confused between external
and extensive
in the extensive form world we're going
to want to think about swap deviations
and there are going to be way more of
the swap deviations and the swap
deviations are going to cause us
difficulty okay let me let me clarify so
what are swap deviations i told you what
internal are internals like whenever i
was playing one action i don't wish i
were playing something else swap is just
thinking about all the ways that i could
transform any of my actions to any other
actions so actions in extensive form
games are now these kind of whole full
strategies on a tree so if we try to
think about all the ways we can
transform one of these things to another
thing we have like lots of exponents and
way too many things to consider
so we would like to minimize swap or
minimize external uh internal sorry
internal regret in extensive form games
the problem is that we can we're gonna
we're gonna find we can't do that
efficiently there are just gonna be too
many of these and that there's not gonna
be an efficient algorithm for doing that
and this was recognized already in 2008
by von stengel and forge did someone
have a question yeah i mean this is drew
i have a question
you're talking about the regret in these
extensive games um and i um can you
explain how that's computed i mean do
players know the strategies other people
are using or having to base this based
only what they saw in the game i don't
understand but i no regret is for hanon
or in a normal form game but i i don't
understand how you're using the term
here
okay excellent question
so i think you're asking whether i'm
kind of in a banded setting or
what's the word for the opposite of the
bandit setting
the full information setting is this is
this the question
uh i don't know the lingo but yeah with
an extensive game i mean okay
just tell
what people deserve at the end of each
period what what's the data that's used
to compute the regret right right right
okay so in practice these games are very
very large and we can't actually visit
the entire tree
but for the story that i'm telling now
i'm kind of imagining that we're
visiting the entire tree and that we're
in just a full information setting which
means that no matter what strategy we
employed maybe we saw uh you know what
would have happened if we did something
else perfect thank you i i was okay that
was the case but since you have
expensive form up there
because because
fine
we can discuss this over the break okay
okay so extensive and expensive i think
i heard expensive form also yeah okay
um
okay so yes let's just imagine we're in
the full information setting i mean on
my last slide i will say future work
let's extend this all to the bandit
setting all right
so um okay so there's going to be too
many internal or swap deviations in the
extensive form world and so von stengel
and forge recognize this and they
propose two possible ways to sort of
simplify the story or to maybe um you
know to to not consider all possible
internal uh or swap deviations okay so
remember we're like kind of throwing
more stuff into the bag so that we can
compare against more kinds of deviations
and we've already achieved external and
we know that external will get us to
coarse correlated equilibria if we
minimize external if all the players
minimize external regret
so we're saying can we get something
stronger than coarse correlated
equilibrium can we do something more can
we put more stuff in the bag but we
can't put in all the internal deviations
so it's going to turn out there's a vast
landscape of possibilities that we can
consider here and we'll consider a bunch
of them today and and you know there's
more to potentially consider
all right so here is the simplification
that came from
stengel and forge the first one um
behavioral deviations uh which i seem
not to have defined yet okay well i'll
define in a few slides and a second one
that they also introduced which are now
called causal deviations for the most
part they called them reduced strategies
we call them causal deviations
all right so something very exciting
happened um so from 2008 to 2000 to 2020
i think maybe we were all asleep
something like that um but then uh in
2020 very exciting work by gabrielle and
his
colleagues uh they developed an
algorithm that could minimize regret for
you know something stronger than
external
called causal
or for reduced strategies um they had an
algorithm that therefore because it's
minimizing this stronger thing was
actually getting more strategic behavior
strategic power and converging to a
tighter equilibrium concept than coarse
correlated equilibrium so it's not faux
correlated equilibrium it's called
extensive form correlated equilibrium
it's something in between
so that was a very monumental and
exciting
development so what this work is about
what we've been thinking about is kind
of my same story that i was thinking
about in 2003 but now in the extensive
form world which is you know what else
can we put in the bag here what are
other kinds of interesting things to
think about so let me just say that um
behavioral which i'll tell you about in
a minute is kind of the the upper limit
so behavioral is is a restriction of
internal and swap but we also can't do
it efficiently
so it's sort of at the top of what we're
thinking about and then there's
causal like behavioral is up here
somewhere and then there's causal which
is down here somewhere and then there's
like maybe a bunch of stuff in between
so we know we can do causal we know we
can do counterfactual there's something
else called action which corresponds to
an agent form correlated equilibrium if
you've heard of that that was in von
stenkel's paper as well those things are
all down here somewhere and then there's
behavioral up here which we can't do and
then there's sort of a vast landscape in
between
and that's what this paper is about
we're exploring this landscape in
between
it's pretty freaking complicated
but you know there's you know
interesting things to to to glean i
think from from the story there
so
yeah
we can't do efficiently that's what i
mean
well i mean that we have too many
possible deviations to look at and so
oh
[Music]
should i say i don't know how to do it
officially
that's a good question
um
um
like i think all the people that i
talked to were like i think it's pretty
believed that this one maybe that swap
like swap regret in accessible games is
hard
so basically finding just one normal
phone for it they believe
so maybe like dynamics are hard but not
competition
but but yeah
so we look forward to the hardness
result of the reunion
um
yeah so the number of deviations there's
so many deviations but maybe this is not
enough of an argument because for cfr
you could think of it there's too many
deviations and yet we had a clever way
to do it
so
again
i mean here it's showing up in a little
bit of a different place which is why
i'm slightly more confident
that
it's still
we would have a hardness result but i
guess i don't have a heart
okay so
here we are
with um same story trying to generalize
from 2003 here we are in 20 years later
and trying to throw more things in the
bag trying to figure out what we can
throw in the bag and maintain efficiency
believing we have an upper limit on on
what would be efficient but i guess that
remains to be established
all right and so what we develop is an
algorithm which we call extensive form
regret minimization and you give your
extensive form regret minimizer a choice
of fee this is kind of how our fee
regret algorithm worked we could give it
any fee we could minimize regret it
would converge to the corresponding
equilibrium defined by that fee
so we're gonna do exactly the same thing
here we're going to have whatever our
class of deviations is we'll feed it to
our extensive form regret minimizing
algorithm it will minimize regret with
respect to those deviations and we will
arrive at some equilibrium corresponding
to that fee so the important thing is
that the fee itself defines the
equilibrium
okay and we have two important special
cases here of
the
this external uh
extensive form
uh regret minimizer
all right yes
like the spectrum of the things on one
end and the other side right so i would
like that and so when i said that it was
pretty freaking complicated it's because
i don't have that but maybe there is a
cleaner formalism in which we can
understand all of these i'm just going
through examples most of this talk is
examples i can tell already i'm gonna
you know run way over so everybody who
wants to stay for lunch and have lunch
here i'll go through all my examples
with you
so you know trying to get our head
wrapped around what what might be a you
know a nice neat way to generalize to
this
all right
all right um so definition of correlated
equilibrium i think most of us know this
i'll just tell you very briefly one way
to think about it is that you get a
recommended each of the players gets a
recommendation and when they get a
recommendation of your recommendation is
chicken conditioned on seeing the
recommendation chicken you can
do a bayesian updating step and sort of
infer what your opponent is going to be
doing so if the
equilibrium is a third or third or third
just on these cells with positive
probability if you get the
recommendation chicken you know that
your opponent is doing half chicken and
half dare
and so with those probabilities you
calculate your expected payoffs for
chicken and your expected payoffs for
dare and you find that you prefer to
play chicken to dare
okay so that's the way
i think about correlated equilibrium and
that corresponds very nicely actually to
the way i think about internal regret
this is for normal form games
okay so that's correlated here is course
correlated so course correlated no
recommendation there's just the
distribution
so here's kind of a funky example
because it
puts some weight on this negative cell
which you don't really want um so sort
of demonstrating that maybe coarse is
not the greatest solution concept out
there
um but here we have a third or third a
third on this diagonal so if i'm the row
player i know there's a third or third a
third on a b and c and so i do the same
thing i calculate my expected rewards
obviously if i play c i get something
negative but calculating my expected
rewards for a and b uh those turn out to
be zero so i'm perfectly happy to just
go with my a third or third a third
which would have given me a payoff of
0.3 in this
example okay so we're considering versus
the best here we're looking at the best
fixed action um you know the best action
in hindsight so this is kind of the
relationship between
external regret minimization and course
correlated equilibrium
okay here are some beautiful slides from
my talk in 2003.
all right so here's how i was oh i still
am thinking about deviations in normal
form games
so
they are ways of transforming an action
so here we have our set of a actions so
we have a function from actions to
actions and maybe the easiest way to
picture this is as stochastic matrices
and so what these stochastic matrices
are doing is their action
transformations so they're telling us
that if we have for example this
external matrix so this matrix is going
to decide that rather than doing
whatever you're doing you should just
play action two so we represent that as
a stochastic matrix which we multiply by
our probabilities on all of our actions
and we end up with all of our weight on
action two
so this is how we represent the external
deviation to action two
and if we want an internal deviation in
this case from two to three
we have
almost
the diagonal matrix but we take all our
weight on two i guess that was here and
we move it to three
okay and hopefully i got my left
multiplication right
okay so if i multiply my strat my my
current uh strategy by this matrix what
it does is it takes all the probability
that i had on two and it moves it over
to three okay so that's how i transform
action two to action three
so we have stochastic agencies that are
representing our um
internal and external regret
okay great
so with that there's a beautiful
algorithm
from
uh
i was going to say from blackwell but
maybe not from blackwell uh maybe from
heart masculine um
satisfying blackwell's approachability
condition which luckily we heard all
about yesterday so we just don't even
have to do this so i'll skip it but the
important thing that i want to tell you
is
about the regret matching algorithm
because it's just a very intuitive and
quite beautiful algorithm so here is the
regret matching algorithm
so what we have here is we have a bunch
of regrets and we have them in fee space
so that means we have regret for not
playing our first deviation our second
deviation our third deviation all the
way up to our deviation so we have a
whole vector of regrets for not playing
any of those deviations
um we'll just look at the positive part
of those regrets
and now what the algorithm is going to
do
is it's going to take as input our fee
matrices so you can think of the
internal the external some combination
of them whatever you want some kinds of
matrices takes is the input those b
matrices and now it computes this convex
combination this convex combination says
let me if i have a lot of regret for you
know my deviation
let me actually weight that
transformation by the regret that i feel
for not having employed that deviation
so this is computing a convex
combination where it's putting weights
exactly with respect to whatever the
regrets were for not
using that deviation
and then it turns out that finding the
fixed point of this matrix is enough to
exactly satisfy blackwell's
approachability condition so that we can
get
a regret minimizing
algorithm so that's how regret matching
works and that's how it kind of puts
these major cs together
um in this clever way
to minimize regret
um here's a proof
uh you can see here's a pi and here's pi
and you know
goes to zero if you use the fixed point
you get zero which means you're like
right on that that hyperplane that you
wanted to be on
all right so one more ingredient we need
now for extern for extensive god i can't
get that right for the extensive form
game setting and that's something called
time selection
uh with regret minimization so time
selection is like this kind of funky
thing where
so if you think of um
all of your fees if you think of them as
experts which we sometimes do
then this has to do with kind of maybe
waking up some of your experts or
trusting some of your experts more on
some of the days
so
for example if i need to commute to
san francisco from here i might and i'm
going like on some weekdays and
sometimes going on some weekends right i
might use a different expert to tell me
the best route on weekdays than i might
to uh on weekends
so what time selection is doing is it's
allowing me to figure out which experts
to pay attention to kind of on or or
maybe maybe allowing me to figure out
you know um
which experts are really uh
sorry that's not right i i have to be
able to regardless of who my expert is
so this is the time selection is going
to be for all possible um waitings for
so for who's ever awake and who's ever
asleep
right at a given time
i want to be able to
with respect to all of those experts and
all of these different times when i wake
them up and put them to sleep or in
general there's just probabilities on
them but um i should achieve the same
kind of no regret condition i had before
but with our weightings involved and of
course with respect to all our
deviations and with respect to all of
the possible weightings and that was
kind of a bumble description but maybe
people have an idea what this is already
all right
so um just another beautiful slide
showing that i can sort of insert my
weights everywhere and i will still be
able to do a blackwell thing with
weights all right we'll need those
weights later good
um
let me pause for
any questions because now we'll get into
uh
our part of the story which i probably
am out of time already does anyone know
what time it is
and how much time do i have
i mean technically eight minutes but
like i don't know i mean it's like you
have a big lunch break after this
okay but if people want to go i'm not
offended so please if you have to go you
just go
but i could go on for another hour so
i'll just plan on that and everybody
just leave as uh
all right so here we have an extensive
form game and now we're going to do
regret minimization and extensive
formats
all right
so um let's see what's important what's
important here is that we have an
information set so this is a place where
one of the cars
yeah the cards were handed out so what
do we have player one got a queen we can
see in both of these player one knows
they have a queen but they can't tell
what player two got player two might
have a jack and player two might have a
king
okay so this this line is kind of
indicating that player one is you know
in a confused state at that moment
between what player two's cards might be
so that's an extensive form game and
this is where we now want to minimize
regret so here's kind of a more abstract
version of that picture i'll just
do a little plug for a model that we've
been uh working with which we call pops
this question came up a lot that's why
i've added this slide um but here's the
game
and what we do
what all of us do when we reason about
extensive form games is we kind of
reason from the point of view of one of
the players
so what this pop model is doing is
giving us a formalism in which to reason
about just one of the players so that's
what i'm showing you here is like here's
player one's possible information sets
or decision points where they need to to
make their moves and here's player twos
over here and so we just kind of break
this thing up into everybody's different
point of view
the real reason i put this in was i
wanted to make a plug for everybody to
come to rldm which is happening in june
in providence
so rldm stands for reinforcement
learning and decision making
and i thought this paper was there but
then it turns out this paper wasn't
there this paper was somewhere else so
but everybody should come to rldm anyway
if you can i'll just rldm is this
wonderful conference which is like what
you could imagine nurips was like 20
years ago
so
it's just neuroscientists and
reinforcement learning researchers
coming together in a much smaller more
intimate environment
all right please come
okay
so here we are with deviations and
extensive form games okay so here i'm
showing you swap deviation so here
here's a picture of a possible strategy
in this game with five nodes in our pop
formalism
and um there are 32 two to the fifth
possible strategies in this game
and now if i want to consider all the
ways that i might
you know change from one to another i
end up with 32 to the 32 of these
deviations
which i'm just gonna say is too many
i don't have a proof
so okay so so that's um
that's those are the swap deviations so
we have to reduce so how are we going to
reduce so here's the reduction for
behavioral deviations that von stangle
and forge introduced what they said is
that when i'm considering
my recommendations at an information set
those recommendations can kind of only
depend on what i've seen so far in the
game so i'm playing over here
and i've been get getting these
recommendations and maybe following
maybe not but
i can't kind of condition or think about
what's happening in some other part of
the game
so remember the definition of correlated
equilibrium like we got our
recommendation and then we did this
bayesian updating and then that gave us
an idea over what everybody else was
doing
so in this behavioral deviation world
i'm going to see my recommendations
along the way but i can't use any
information from any other part of the
tree
if i have to think about all that stuff
on the other part of the tree that's
where we're kind of it's
getting too big okay so that's that's
the reduction that we're making and let
me just show you in an example of uh you
know kind of what we're missing by by um
by looking only at behavioral deviations
so here is an example of a game which is
a bit like matching pennies let me
explain how this is written so we're
looking at payoffs from the point of
view of player one those are the payoffs
down here
and um there are two possible
recommendations that happen with
probability 50 50.
so in this
the recommendation is the bolded stuff
so this in this recommendation um player
one is recommended this stuff that's
bold and player two is heads and in the
other recommendation player two is tails
so the point of this example is that
this is in fact a behavioral correlated
equilibrium
even though
there's kind of this unfortunate thing
happening where in recommendation one
player one is getting
only minus two
uh payoff
so if we look at the swap deviation
we can see
that there's an opportunity for player
one to do better instead of following
this recommendation over here they can
go ahead and switch to playing h and
they would get plus two
but the reason that the behavioral
deviation rules this out is because the
only way that player one can figure out
that it'd rather swap over here to h is
based on this other stuff that's
happening in another part of the tree
where player one didn't go where the
recommendations didn't go so overheat
well
under recommendation one right so we
came over here in recommendation one
and the only thing that's different
right because recommendation one is the
same
uh as recommendation two of this
everything is the same here but the only
thing that's different is when player
one
got here
they had to look at this other part of
the tree
that they didn't
go to
in order to can you can you see what i
mean like here this is an h and here
this is a t so you have to condition on
information in a different part of the
tree where you're not
in order to figure out that you wanted
to make this swap
does that make sense like the behavioral
deviation rules this out you're not
allowed to look at what's happening in
this other part of the tree where you
didn't visit
how is which different so efce is going
to be a special case of the behaviorals
so probably i didn't check but we you
know this may be an efc also
these are great questions and we're
getting there i hope uh here we already
got there that's great okay all right
any other questions on this example
before i answered that
okay
so here is a picture of
known basic behavioral deviations in
efgs this may be as far as i have time
to get i mean this and a couple of
examples this may be as far as i have
time to get today but let me just tell
you that i have a much uglier picture
with way more stuff kind of in between
here so like we were trying to put more
stuff into the bag and get stronger
while maintaining efficiency get
stronger
convergence all right so here's here's
how to read this picture so we have
three kinds of things this is our key
over here right so we have trees we have
sequences and we have actions we also
have three colors
um so the black color means identity
which means you've been given a
recommendation and you follow your
recommendation
the red means you deviate this is like
an external deviation you just go do
whatever you want to do
and then the blues are things that are
recommended so for example internal
is i got a recommendation and i switched
to another entire tree like some other
thing completely doing that instead okay
so those are the internal
uh transformations in the extensor form
game down here we have external which is
just like i go and do any of these um
strategies all you know fixed in
hindsight whatever any one of them that
i want
so over here we're kind of counting how
many of these things there are so
external we got this number and internal
we got that number if you can think
about these things and we can talk about
them later if there are questions um but
you know a problem is these these i
exponents so i is the number of
information sets so those were the
decision points in our pops
okay so we don't like eyes and exponents
that's bad
okay so here we have eyes and exponents
for external
but
we said that cf stands for
counterfactual there are not eyes in in
in the exponent for counter factual so
counterfactual again is like this great
miracle because without having an eye on
the exponent we managed to minimize
external regret
okay
so
let's discuss this picture a little bit
so up here at the top we have internal
and here's the interesting the kind of
ones that we've talked a little bit
about so far so causal are the ones that
define efce okay so efce stands for
extensive form correlated equilibrium
um i think when von stengel originally
defined extensive uncorrelated
equilibrium he might have been referring
to what we're now calling behavioral
correlated equilibrium anything defined
by any of these behavioral
transformations however um
the language has kind of
stuck so efce is referring to the causal
uh transformations okay so what is
causal so causal says we've been going
along and following recommendations for
a while
and now we consider
when we get some recommend this is an
informed causal you can be informed when
you have these blue lines so i get a
recommendation and i decide oh well i'd
rather do something else instead so this
is what's happening right here at the
bottom is whether i'm using one of my n
squared
transformation matrices for all of my
internal transformations or if i'm in
the blind case i'm just using one of my
n transformation matrices
i guess i should say one other important
thing which i would have said at the end
but i don't have time which is that the
counter factual regret minimization
algorithm
is kind of you know it's amazing in what
it achieves but it's also super simple
like it's a super straightforward idea
what it does i mean all it does is take
your regret minimizing algorithm and run
it at every single one of the
information states that's all it's doing
it's just running a regret minimizer
everywhere i mean it's running a regret
minimizer with you know long-term
information which is what drew was
asking about earlier it's assuming that
somehow it has all the information it
needs to run those regret minimizers but
all it's doing is running those regret
minimizers locally everywhere okay so
that's how the algorithm is running so i
just mentioned that because you could
locally run an internal regret minimizer
or an external regret minimizer
counterfactual regret was always running
external but this picture is saying hey
what if you run an internal layer
instead of an external
okay so
so the difference between causal and
counterfactual is the following causal
follows recommendations first
then maybe gets a recommendation or
maybe deviates with one action and then
after causal deviates i think i skipped
that on the earlier slide but what von
stengel said for reduced strategies was
after a deviation no more
recommendations like that was the second
way of limiting you know of finding a
more restricted class of deviations so
you follow for a while you get a
recommendation but if you deviate from
that recommendation it's all over for
you
you won't see anything else in the
future so thereafter you're in an
external world you're just on your own
on the other hand counterfactual is kind
of this funny thing where you decide hey
i'm just going to deviate someplace
then maybe i'll get a recommendation
maybe i won't and then after i deviate
someplace i'm going to re-correlate
it's going to get to re-correlate so
that's kind of the idea like
re-correlate means like go back to
following recommendations go back to uh
identity case
okay so can you see that causal and
counterfactual somehow
inverses of one another
and so the more general thing that we're
going to have on this slide that i'm not
going to get to is going to be something
that starts with black
and then you know
get some recommendations here then does
some red and maybe gets another
recommendation here and then goes back
to black
okay so that's like our best algorithm
actually the one that minimizes regret
with exactly like cross out this red
triangle minimize regret with respect to
that picture that i kind of just
highlighted
okay so that's kind of the strongest
form of deviation that we have so far um
well you could do stronger but but every
time you as you do stronger you
there's some cost
in your efficiency of your algorithm
okay so now noah can you ask your
question again or do you want to see
some examples now we have some examples
coming of what like that would
distinguish that would distinguish these
equilibrium concepts
all right so one thing to say is here's
a picture kind of showing that these
things
every single one of these defines a
class of equilibria right all of these
different ways that you can deviate it's
a fee so we have the fee equilibria when
we minimize regret with respect to these
kinds of deviations
yeah that was just what i was mentioning
before if whether we're using internal
or external regret matrices at each of
our information sets so like am i
potentially seeing another
recommendation before i
uh does that make sense if i'm using n
squared or just n matrices at each okay
yeah
that's the only difference there
oh i didn't mention action but action is
uh also something that von schtengel
studied and actually it doesn't imply uh
right so these are all implications
that's what i wanted to say so this is
our strongest you know this is our
weakest so up here we have correlated
here we have course correlated here we
have something we just called it
behavioral this is behavioral correlated
equilibrium this is efce and this is
counterfactual and then you know action
is just sitting out here in outer space
not implying external but all of these
are implying course correlated you can
see from this picture that efce is
stronger than course correlated so the
next slide this table is showing us
actually that these two
columns are distinct so counterfactual
and uh causal equilibria we have
examples where we satisfy one and we
don't satisfy the other and so i don't
know if we really have time to go into
the yeah
i could go for another hour so i don't
know
i should wrap it up okay i have these
examples i'm really happy to share them
with anybody who wants to see them so
these are examples that will
differentiate between causal and
counterfactual which i told you are uh
distinct
then i have a little bit about the
algorithm won't have time for that one
okay i'm just going to wrap up i think
i've told you a lot
um there's a lot more to uh that's the
really ugly picture okay so let's just
make that go away bless you yeah that
causes people to i don't get sick or
something
the sight of it yeah but here's our
here's um the the the strongest
deviations we've been playing with we
call them twice informed and that was
sort of the merging of the two pictures
and i'll just close by showing you some
experiments here these experiments are
you know we we can if we want to
implement behavioral on these very small
games that we've tested so far so here's
behavioral up here at the top it's
getting the highest rewards in these
examples
we can also look at any of the ones in
that picture we can we've implemented
them all right all you have to do is
give a different set of deviations to
these uh to the algorithm and you end up
with a different um you know it's a very
general algorithm that's parameterized
by the deviations
so um here we can see that tips which is
the one that we called that we had up
top there the twice informed
uh partial sequence um that's doing
you know in some cases almost as well as
behavioral
it's a little more expensive than the
others um what you st this picture is
kind of amazing to me and surprising
like here this this pink line above here
is counterfactual so in that example
counterfactual is actually doing better
than tips which i didn't expect so that
requires further uh investigation
it's more deviations yeah right so does
it seem like a bug yeah maybe i don't
know it's surprising yeah why does
convergence to a stronger equilibrium
concept imply better reward couldn't
there just be worse equilibria and a
stronger concept
yeah yeah so you're just wandering
around the space but you're wandering
around a smaller space maybe with lower
valued equilibrium yeah that's right
like if you're in a bigger space you can
get higher valued equilibrium okay no
above i don't really think there's about
justin it's very good
i mean like also if you have to be
robust towards like against more
deviations it might take you longer to
learn like a bit of a living so it might
be like convergence also kind of like a
question
i said like even like
yeah but it looks pretty flat but yes
yeah it's not really changing but maybe
there would be some change that would
yeah
okay um i have a summary of my whole
story but i've gone on enough so i'll
take questions oh wait sorry one more
thing this is very important
okay so okay yeah just future what are
we doing next so we've implemented this
algorithm on small games of course we
want to solve big games right people are
talking about hanabi people talked about
diplomacy these kinds of games that we
would hopefully like to solve and and
you know eventually we'll try to scale
up efr you know we'll have to do all the
stuff you know cfr has been very
successful but with lots of bells and
whistles so we'll have to spend 10 years
adding bells and whistles to efr and
then see what efr can do so we'll get
started on that soon um but in the
meantime our picture is very complicated
right so we're looking at a very
complicated story here and i think you
know
this is the best that we or you know our
our best intuition about a trade-off i
mean this is just an intuitive thing
where we where dustin really you know
implemented exactly this
uh set of deviations between behavioral
and the stuff down here
um
but that's not necessarily the right
answer right so there's a vast space in
here and maybe there's a simpler picture
maybe there's an easier way to
understand
everything going on here and and the
real question that we want to answer is
you know what's the largest assuming the
conjecture that behavioral is too
expensive right that that would not be
the yield an efficient algorithm so
assuming that or maybe not even assuming
that what i was going to say is what's
the largest class within behavioral but
really more generally what is the
largest class for which we can have an
efficient no regret algorithm that's
that's the open question
okay thanks
[Applause]
do we have any questions
oh yeah questions
[Music]
i guess could you give us like just a
hint of the ideas for the design of the
algorithm i mean i mean i guess i don't
know if that's the right time to do it
but
yeah
um
i mean i could but we'll have another
few minutes
any other shorter questions but i will i
will yeah
uh
yeah
so so in your experiment are you showing
the last trade
oh no no no that was
yeah the
those those are just the average rewards
oh yeah oh okay actually
right we're not showing um
dustin are you on the call
you're sure
sorry the secretary
oh sorry uh justin said he couldn't hear
the question oh right okay yeah
yeah dustin we're just curious a little
bit more about the experimental setup
and what exactly we're plotting here
when we say average payoffs
i think we can hear you with utah if you
want to mute yourself
hello can you hear me
sorry yes
okay um yeah so
it is the average reward while the agent
is learning
uh on the left set of the left column
that's where the
um the opponents that the agent is
learning with are static
like they're not responding to what the
agent is doing
um it is a sequence of strategies that
changes as uh like over time over the
across rounds it's just not reacting to
the way that the agent is behaving
uh on the
for the the results on the right column
all of the agents are learning together
simultaneously
okay thanks
zero sum non zero sum
sure yeah so uh the the first
uh goof spiel game there is zero sum uh
and two player
the the second goof spiel um is
three players and non-zero sum
and then sheriff is a two-player
non-zero sum
um they're all imperfect information
games
um
yeah goof spiel is a pretty classic card
game
uh and sheriff is like a small a
miniature version of the sheriff
nottingham board game if you're familiar
with
that uh let's see
are there any other questions
oh okay
quick question so the blind uh causal
causal one is that i think is that
sometimes referred to as efcce
then uh the informed causal is efce yeah
that's right exactly exactly exactly yes
thanks yeah thank you i didn't even
mention thanks yeah so in that whole
table that's a good point yeah so when
we have informed we're getting to ce's
and we have blind we're getting to cces
and that's exactly a function of which
matrices we're using at those
information sets yeah i'm happy to stick
around and talk about the algorithm
um
all right yeah maybe we should stop it
there and let people go to lunch but
yeah as amy has said she's very uh happy
to keep telling you about it if you want
to uh you know you know stay for another
hour talk to her yeah yeah
all right thanks a lot let's thank amy
again
[Applause]
thanks to all of you for staying sorry
to keep you from lunch no it's very it's
a very fun talk guys